Thor: Love and Thunder, the fourth Thor solo
flick is scheduled to rocket into theaters
on November 5th, 2021.
That's more than enough to send fans racing
to mark their calendars, but a major question
remained after Marvel Studios announced Love
and Thunder's release date.
We know when it's coming to the big screen,
but when does it take place in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe?
Thor is a little flighty when it comes to
keeping track of time, afterall.
"He's gonna come back."
"Except, you know, last time he was gone for
like… two years…"
Thanks to Marvel luminary James Gunn, who
was not long ago reinstated as the writer
and director of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
3, we have an answer.
In the comments section of his recent Instagram
post congratulating Avengers: Endgame on beating
Avatar at the box office, Gunn fielded a question
about Thor: Love and Thunder's place in the
MCU in relation to Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 3.
A fan inquired whether Love and Thunder will
be set before or after the new Guardians flick,
and Gunn gave a simple, one-word answer: "Before."
Gunn's response was clear - the fourth Thor
comes before the third Guardians - but it
opens up a whole can of worms and invites
a lot of speculation.
The last we saw of the God of Thunder was
at the end of Avengers: Endgame, where he
was sporting a brand-new physique and a renewed
interpretation of what it means to be a superhero,
handing the kingship of New Asgard over to
Valkyrie, and teaming up with the Guardians
of the Galaxy gang.
Now, Marvel filmmakers and screenwriters basically
never do anything without serious forethought.
It's for this reason that we can imagine Thor
and the Guardians will be together at least
at the start of Thor: Love and Thunder to
pick up from where their story left off in
Endgame — exactly like how the events of
Avengers: Infinity War started mere moments
after the action of Thor: Ragnarok ended.
"I feel like everything's going to work out
fine."
Gunn's confirmation of when in the MCU Thor:
Love and Thunder takes place unfortunately
doesn't address when Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 3 will debut in theaters.
Prior to the Walt Disney Company booting him
from the film after unsavory past tweets of
his surfaced, Gunn was planning for the next
entry in his franchise to premiere sometime
in 2020.
Plans changed after he was fired, when Warner
Bros. and DC Films poached Gunn to write and
direct The Suicide Squad, a reboot-slash-sequel
to David Ayer's Suicide Squad.
As we all know, the House of Mouse eventually
changed its tune and tapped Gunn to come back
on board - but by then, Gunn was committed
to a different movie in a totally different
comic book film franchise.
Gunn has since stated that he'll finish The
Suicide Squad before starting production on
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3, so that previously
projected 2020 release date is no longer valid.
Neither are those past predictions that Guardians
3 would be a Phase 4 movie.
At San Diego Comic-Con 2019, Marvel dropped
a slate of five movies and five television
shows arriving in 2020 and 2021, which studio
head Kevin Feige has said is the "complete"
Phase 4 for the time being.
There's no sign of Guardians on that slate,
which seems to mean that the next time we
see the Guardians trying to save the galaxy,
it'll be in Phase 5, probably in 2022 or 2023.
There are still some lingering questions when
it comes to Thor: Love and Thunder and Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3, but we know two things
for sure: Love and Thunder will bring us Natalie
Portman's Jane Foster as Mighty Thor, and
will introduce Valkyrie as the first openly
LGBTQ+ superhero in the MCU.
It may or may not have the Guardians of the
Galaxy in it, but Love and Thunder is definitely
going to be both lovely and thunderously fun.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.